welcome back to another Collider heroes
interview I'm Amy Dallen I'm quadrant ro
and we are joined today by one half of
one of my very favorite writing teams
out there and also a buddy of mine
Jackson Lanza I've come to Collider
heroes what's that baby thank you I'm so
happy to be here
you've been talking about this for ages
like every time I run into coy in the
wild I'm just like hey I think it's
approaching a year thanks Jen luck we
had to make it happen for you are
writing the first gen lock comics with
Colin Kelly of course yes can you tell
us a little bit about this project and
how it came to be yeah of course so Jenn
lock is a an adaptation of the rooster
teeth animated series which is you know
just read on Adult Swim they just
announced season two on HBO max yeah
that's by the way yeah yeah they're
blowing up it's awesome um Jim Locke is
at its heart at American anime it's it's
taking a lot of the same constructors
and conventions of like a mecha anime
and then applying it to a very like
Western story so the idea is that in the
future um you know some 40 50 years from
now the world is split into two sides we
have the polity which is effectively the
United Nations it's it's what we
understand is sort of like a pluralist
society futuristic I'm a cyberpunk very
positive and then on the other side you
have the Union the union of the fourth
turning republics and the union of the
fourth learning Republic's is a group of
effectively like techno fascists who are
very interested in you believing exactly
what they believe to the degree that
they might put a computer in your head
and make sure that you believe what they
believe
yeah the Union are great the series
opens with the Union taking out
Manhattan literally just going in with
advanced technology that polity is never
seen taking over Manhattan taking most
of the citizens of Manhattan into their
army effectively like taking them and
stealing them away and we have a or lens
into it as a kid named Julian chase
Julian chase the guy on the cover here
right in the front is played by Michael
B Jordan who produces the series no it's
insane and we'll get to that in a second
so Jordan
crashes in his spoiler alert crashes in
his chat in the first episode and as a
result is effectively almost dies and
the polity government takes him in for
the next few years they used what's left
of his body and what's left of his mind
and program it into this giant robot
that you might see behind you guys
that's what's called a halt on he can
basically decant his mind take his brain
out of his body and put it into this
giant robot body and then he can run
around and fly and beat stuff up and
generally be an awesome walking tank for
the the fight against the Union gen lock
really begins when he gets his team a
whole bunch of new people who don't have
the same sort of trauma that he's gone
through who are all themselves learning
how to put their minds into these robots
and so they as a team of five Hollens go
out and fight for the polity and fight
against the Union and try to keep you
know truth and justice winning the day
so in that way it's very much like a
superhero book it's really about
fighting for core ideals working with
your friends understanding what you're
becoming as you gain more power it's
just set in this cool new science
fiction universe that DC fans haven't
seen before and we're gonna get into all
of this but you know something about
science fiction universes and
superheroes you have written for the
Batman family for Green Arrow himself
you are currently writing an incredibly
exciting Star Trek book been a lot a lot
of fun and also I've played a lot of pen
and paper tablecloth role-playing games
with you so I know you know from sci-fi
yeah yeah I'm not kidding around alright
so I got to know from a futurist
standpoint because any of these
sentences five years ago would seem
absurd this is a comic adaptation that
starts digital coming out in print that
is based off of a series of American
animes that take place on both multiple
networks and a soon-to-be-released
HBO platform that is digital only all of
that's insane yes sir so I just living
in the future just like not as that
would make sense even like it's meaning
that to my parents my question weird for
you who's you've been in the comics game
a long time which is a tangible medium
right to be writing something that is so
digital and it takes place in a digital
platform as produced by Michael B
fricking Jordan is it a different animal
when you're making something like this
then say Green Arrow of course yeah
absolutely um but Oh
not at all so the there are two real
distinct differences here one is just
what the source material is so with
green arrow its it doesn't in dozens of
years of comics that I've loved and read
and that's a character that I care for
and really know and want to dig down
into right and so that's the IP that's
the the pre-existing content and then
I'm gonna go into that I'm gonna find
what I think is interesting we're really
genuinely I'm gonna find what Colin and
I think is interesting imagine there's
like an invisible guy yeah Colin Kelly
is like the other half of my brain we do
everything together so assume we do a
debate about it yes so that's really the
only real distinction here in terms of
like the source material side is just I
had to watch it on roosterteeth that's
the only distinction like I had to go on
the internet and watch it as opposed to
sitting there with a book and reading it
there's nothing more or less tangible
about that to me just cuz I work in film
and television so I'm kind of used to
the script being the tangible medium if
it ever comes about then that's an extra
blessing that's a wonderful thing that
happened oh the thing got made but the
only the only time you ever really know
you're gonna get made is when you're
working in comics you're writing that
thing so 98 percent chance it's gonna
get printed and that's exciting on the
other side of this though it's a digital
first comic yeah and that is different
okay so the first comics are a thing
that DC does um that are really fun but
ultimately split the release window into
there for people who are reading caught
who maybe aren't like Wednesday warriors
aren't like people who are heading to
their comic shop aren't really knowing
what they want they don't have a pull
list
they don't necessarily read comics on
the daily maybe this is the first comic
they've ever read which for a lot of
genlock fans I know is true they will
then go on a comiXology and that first
ten pages is gonna be an episode of the
conic we call it a chapter every issue
of the comic is two chapters so we'll
take chapters 1 & 2 shuffle together
boom you've got issue 1 next Wednesday
November 6 then you should all be
picking up but you can get a preview of
in this manner right now indeed so what
we end up doing is creating a story that
effectively runs all seven issues of the
book which book will be 77 if you
by the end that'll be 14 chapters if you
just can't wait for the print issue if
you're a John Locke fan you want it now
go on comiXology the first three
episodes or chapters are already out the
fourth chapter will be out this
Wednesday which by this point will be
last Wednesday and it comes out every
two weeks from there on out so the
digital first version of the book will
end well before the print copy shipped
but if you're a print fan you like
getting your books in print you like
going to your comic shop you just want
to put on your pull list not worry about
any of that great the print issues are
gonna be out there for you and obviously
it looks gorgeous in print you will see
there's a certain there's also there's a
cover on this one yeah talk about
speaking of things being in print Jim
Lee Jim Jim Lee cover it's my first
while I'm tan Genting on a Jim Lee cough
it's really exciting reading that email
getting that photo how did the how did
you handle they actually acted so they
treated it like it was like a footnote I
I heard about it in the know yeah I
heard about it in the announcement I was
at r-tx which is the Rooster Teeth
convention where we were announcing the
books I was getting to know the
incredible Rasheed fan base all the
great people at our Tea themselves it
was an awesome weekend by the way RTX is
like a killer con even if you're not a
roosterteeth fan like even if you don't
know anything they do you will know them
and love them by the end of the con it's
awesome
so we obviously I was in a privileged
position to for that to be the case but
I had a blast
we went out to RTX they were announcing
the book they announced Ruby and genlock
at the same time because this is part of
an initiative with another book ruby by
Marguerite Bennett and we were sitting
there in the audience listening to the
Ruby announcement and they timed The
Hollywood Reporter to go out with a
press release at the exact same time so
Paul and I are sitting on our phones
being like we finally talked about
genlock we finally talked about just
like posting Evangelion gifs to my
Twitter and being like somebody will
guess and I was like a rare you know can
I talk about it can I talk about it and
finally it hits on there and like I can
talk about it and then Colin goes what I
look over and he's reading it he's gone
down to the bottom where it says and
they'll be incentive variants by Jim
Leon ever I'm sorry
yeah so we both had to be really quiet
cuz there was a panel going on so we're
just sitting there between the two of us
being like and that was on top of the
fact that we already knew that Dan Mauro
was doing our covers who is one of my
favorite working artists so the fact
that we got to work with Dan Morra we
got Jim lead gracing us with this
incredible mecha cover and then the
interiors which are all by Carlo barbary
who is himself a wonderful artist with a
storied history I think it's been a
really um it's been a wonderful way to
like kick this thing off because digital
first comics can be kind of chaotic and
learning how to speak that language can
be a unique challenge so getting to do
it with such incredible artists was like
a blast so I want to hear more about the
process of but first what is it in the
story in the world of genlock that
really thrills you so two things big
first is as you said I know from sci-fi
universes if you can give me a big
universe to play in I'm really excited
because world building is a core thing
that call them and I love to do and we
don't get a chance to do it all that
much in comics frankly just because
we're tend to work in like you're not
gonna do that much world building on
gotham city when you're dealing with you
know Batman and Robin eternal like
though you could create your very own
version of Azrael who then gets
merchants was that places we we could
and that was a blast and continues to be
I just bought an entire like $600 board
game just cuz I had a mini of our Azrael
and that was a whole thing but no I I
love the chance of getting able being
able to just dig into this world we are
just past season one of genlock season
two is just starting up right now and as
a result we actually got an opportunity
to get into this world early to get the
creator of the show and roosterteeth all
on board with essaying a corner of the
world that hadn't been tested before and
making that cannon so that was really
exciting because it meant that we could
just actually build out part of this
world ourselves from what inspired us
about the show that was really exciting
and then I want to speak to the second
element just cuz it's a it's a thing
that's close to my heart
and something that I call that I try to
work into a lot of our stories so I was
gonna get heavy for a second but I was
born with spina bifida I had it my whole
life it's a degenerative condition I'll
had it for the rest of my life and I
have a struggle sometimes with my body
trying to figure out what I can do what
I can't do I can't run I can't jump but
I used to be a soccer player like
learning how to really completely adjust
the way that I live my life because of
how I
how I am able is a very unique challenge
and it's something that again I'm very
privileged it's a really I've it so much
better than most people in my position
but it's still a struggle and it's still
something that I can speak to very like
like from my heart a big thing about
genlock and Evan Narcisse who wrote on
genlock season one who's a friend said
something that really impacted me about
this in gen lock you have chase who
cannot leave his he's his body and he
has no legs anymore he barely has a
working poor so he's in a pod and the
only time he gets to go anywhere or do
anything is when you take his mind you
put it in this giant robot right and by
the end of season one Chase is really
without getting into spoiler territory
has really adapted to that body has
really started thinking of that body as
his body not as a prosthesis not as a
addition to his body but as his body and
a lot of stories even characters like DC
characters like cyborg spend a lot of
their time being like Oh does that mean
I'm not human anymore what does that
make me I'm a monster that's like the
classic story of my brain being put in a
giant body umm genlock very specifically
says no we're not gonna tell the story
that way we're gonna tell the story of a
guy who's becoming more and more human
and becoming more and more himself at
what Evan said is I'm not it's like I'm
the upgrade is the way that chase thinks
about his not himself and to me that's a
really powerful message for somebody who
deals with being differently abled um so
I thought that was a really exciting
place to jump off and then you're
dealing with these four other characters
who were experiencing that in their own
way how does getting into the Hollins
free them to be more themselves which is
really exciting
I love diagram that's that's the pitch
for me cuz I so admittedly this is new
to me and I I was being acclaimed
roosterteeth because I'm an 80 year old
man so all of this is really exciting
because I love discovering new things
through comic books and now there's a
new way to discover a new thing through
comic books through the digital platform
branching off from a cartoon which i
think is an incredible outlet in writing
these as chapters we were talking right
before about how you write differently
for the animation style yeah as splash
pages for example are totally different
that fascinated me can you dive into
don't let that relearning for you
because you've written comics for a long
time but this is a completely new format
how does that change things so we
got a little bit of a cheat code on this
because a couple years back we did
Gotham City garage at DC which was a
digital first series which must read by
the way thank you love the DC heroes and
alternate versions of them which you all
do it is my new fake look one of my new
favorite Elseworlds oh thank you that
means the world to me
we had a absolute blast with it it was
such a great series and in a real
motorcycle and rotating crew quarters
it's it's it's it's Mad Max girl gang DC
you basically it was a blast and weekend
like an amazing amount of incredible
artists karma Cornero who's now killing
it on Captain Marvel Darick Robertson
like we don't want to Bryan Chang we
like great people in the book um
but all of those artists including us
had to learn how to work in the digital
first format because every page of a
digital first comic might show this yet
so every page of a digital first comic
has to be cut halfway between the panel
run right so you have screen 1 and
screen - you're not gonna see this whole
page in the digital format because your
iPhone is a horizontal screen you're
gonna see it like this then you gonna
see this turn the page and you're gonna
see this and then you gonna see this I'm
gonna see this let's see this and
continues and continues right so that
means that you can't do certain things
that you would normally do in a comic um
Colin and I with apologies to Tom King
love 9 male grit so we are going to
sorry time I have to review we we have
to avoid using 9 panel can't use it
occasionally we'll write 8 panel grid
now um like the Morrison from
Multiversity a panel grid because that
you can do you can cut a panel in half
it's 4 panels and 4 panels but 9 panels
is three panels three panels three
panels you kind of horizontal line
through that the character so you can't
use nine panel um the other thing is
like splash pages right what you want to
make sure you have on a splash page are
two focuses so you have an upper focus
at a bottom focus you have a villain
reveal and the character reacting to the
villain and they can be in the same
panel for her they can be a splash page
but you have to find a way to sell that
in digital first yeah then when it comes
back around a print you have something
really cool now I'll show you my biggest
cheat code though we figured this out on
Gotham City Garage cuz early in gcg we
were like gzg follows a Kara effectively
Supergirl but she's grown up as Kara
Gordon
she finds herself running away from the
place that she's lived her whole life
sand and out into the desert because of
stuff that's happened I can almost boil
the book to you but she's running from
Batman and she runs out and she gets out
and she gets under the desert and she's
saved by this group of women on
motorcycles Harley Quinn and silver
banshee and Catwoman they all roll out
of the desert we were like I want this
as a DPS like I want to be able to see
this and see a double-page spread I
wanna be able to just for a second for
my RPG audience yeah I said I want to
just take the whole two pages and
dedicate it to this single image it may
be like a little run of stuff along the
bottom that would be really fun but in
digital first how do you do that how do
you program that right and what we
realized was digital first was super
fine with doing double-page spreads so
we can do them right there's a DPS from
gen lock one right and so this is a
screen and then this is a screen and
then this is a screen yeah right and as
long as you can find a way to screen
that out you don't want to do it on
every page because that makes it really
hard for whoever actually has to do that
side of things I want to be a dick but
it does let you get a right get away
with more traditional comic book
language so that when it's printed
ideally you don't look at it and go oh
this is a digital first comic yeah I
want you to have a really seamless
experience on digital and then have a
really seamless experience on print and
that's that the goal is always to find a
way to do both I don't know we always
succeed at that but we try I love that
perspective and and speaking of
perspective I've enjoyed the hell out of
a book right now that is that a
switching perspectives that is causing
much mystery in you we're dealing with
this right before all this took place I
want to talk about a middle of my
Leviathan and your work leading up to it
all of that madness heck yeah
what was that like knowing something was
coming not being able to talk about it
having that level of secrecy and writing
a character that was gonna be integral
to something that you were like well so
yeah it was it was it was it was hard so
I'm no secret to secrecy Colin I work in
film and TV we can't talk about 90% of
what we do that said as a me well knows
I'm a chatterbox my life lies so for me
there's appreciate that you're awesome
but my face betrays me but I think
what's been really cool about working on
the vent
and are working as a lead up to a fella
fine because I did not work that was
when you were writing green that was
when I was writing green arrow was I
didn't really know that that's what was
happening when we started we started on
green arrow and then we were sort of
starting up our run and figuring out
what we were gonna do with it and then
we got a notice you know from our we got
a call from our editor and we were
talking about and they were like you
know sort of interesting news as we get
up into the Leviathan Brian Michael
Bendis is going to want to use green
arrow and we were both sitting there
being like yeah so we're just setting up
by Michael Bendis right that's what
we're doing that's that's like a thing
that is real in the world that we're
doing is good understand I I probably
only write comics because I found Bendis
at the right time like his work changed
my life so I'm and continues to change
my life
frankly um so I've spent a lot of my
life looking at his work trying to
understand how he does what he does and
how to not to replicate it cuz you don't
wanna you know I got my own voice I got
my own thing I want to do but man alive
somebody up like he's the guy to set up
that's amazing yeah so it was really
nice what we had to what we ended up
doing was sitting down and and
understanding what he needed to go into
it without really understanding anything
about about within itself but knowing
that going into that we needed to have
all a stripped down we needed to you
know really break up his trust in the
Justice League we needed to break up his
relationship with Dinah we needed to
really set a standard where he didn't
have to be stuck in Seattle like we
really have to just blow up a lot of the
book which was different than what we
were initially planning on doing so it
sort of set us back and were like
alright what are we really what are we
gonna do here at which point the
conversation becomes alright how many
issues do we have to do that eventually
we realized due to several things that
the books can end at issue 50 so we
started issue 48 we're gonna end 50s
where runs gonna stop pretty quickly
but we're gonna get that issue 50 which
is a huge so cool right and the end and
all we get to do in issue 50 is end this
just like what's Green Arrow the end how
do you blow up his house how do you blow
of his plane have you blow up his
relationship ID blow up his trust how do
you blow up his status quo then you blow
up everything and that was like the most
citing challenge because that's the kind
of thing you don't get to do on these
books if we'd walked in on green or
initially and been like we want to blow
up everything we've never have gotten
the job but we instead came in with this
different take and it never happened and
instead it was like you know how do you
now that we're here what advantage do we
get for getting to do this and it was
like we get to take this really
seriously
and so issue 50 I think is my favorite
comic we've ever written I think Green
Arrow 50 is is I put it up against
anything we've ever done it's the
hardest thing we've written fitting all
of that into every page was really
difficult finding ways to hand that off
because we wasn't just in that Leviathan
we were setting up we were also being
impacted by heroes in crisis because Roy
had died in heroes crisis and that had
taken up our first two issues and then
we were dealing with the box that had
been left behind and no justice which
had been set up by Scott Snyder and by
the Bensons so we had a lot of things to
play with and it was really on us to not
say oh well none of that matters because
if we say oh well none of that matters
then why did it happen why did he resume
crisis to do that why did the box show
up over here why are we heading into an
alibi lethen with this character why is
any of that matter to this person to
this character and the readers of green
arrow to people who this has been the
book on their poll how do we make sure
that all of that all of these threads
that could get picked up in five years
or whatever get picked up now by us and
made relevant and that was like we
didn't want to pass the buck we wanted
to make sure that it worked and to DC's
enormous credit they were deeply
supportive of it and we managed to I
think create a book that I mean Hobby
fernández's work alone in that book I
think kind of made him like I think it
got everybody noticing him because he
immediately went over to Justice League
he immediately went over to tune out arc
multiverse like we still talk all the
time but if like hobbies booked for like
two years in advance I don't what I get
to work with this guy again he's
incredible and that cover
I mean well and then and then we got a
Kevin Nolan cover that goes like a
minor-league viral because like he's
like taking off the mask and then we get
that doc shader cover that is my
favorite cover of all time
it's crazy creator Tom King Brian
Michael Bendis all of these artists like
I mean come on he's on Santa
congratulations and a thank you like
it's incredible congratulations it's
been a blast thank you so much
we're gonna have to trick you into
coming back again because there's so
much more we want to talk through you
are literally you've gone from setting
up Bendis to following up Star Trek the
original series and as of Wednesday next
week you can get issue one of genlock at
your friendly local comic book store you
can be reading the digital chapters
right now you can dive into all of that
you can look forward to season two and
you can follow Jack on the Internet
where can they find you I'm on Twitter
at Jack's and Lansing if you want like
much more personal stuff you can find me
on Instagram it sound in the wild where
you can see what I'm eating and how cute
my cat is and you can find my other half
at CP Kelly he's delightful we will
steal him for that robot conversation to
find out who is who that is going to
happen and you and I are gonna talk
Korean our Batman on my order this going
down thank you for joining us today in
Claudia thank you so much guys until
next time stay sweaty